Welcome back everyone is going to be my full
Rick and Morty season 5 episode 7 video there
were a whole bunch of Anime references a whole
bunch of callbacks to previous episodes including
a giant literal and metaphorical callback
to earlier in season five.
So we'll break it all down.
You're brand-new to the channel, be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'm also doing a Rick and Morty merge giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your favorite Easter egg from the
episode on the video careful for spoilers
if you have not see the episode yet will start
with moments and Easter eggs the beginning
the episode and work our way through shot
by shot elves number these as we go along
to stay organized starting with the title
of the episode Gotron Jerrysis Rickvangelion
a reference to Voltron and neon genesis Evangelion
you could also call this episode one with
the giant space baby for the giant twin says
baby from earlier this season.
They also heavily parodied a lot of the plot
of famous mob movies like Goodfellas and Scarface.
I also love that they named the giant space
baby naruto that's Canon now in the baby is
still alive at the end of the episodes was
still floating around in outer space out there
somewhere.
But the opening scene is them actually paying
off a reference from way back during season
four with blue world back during season four
episode five the terminator snakes episode
at the end of the episode.
Rick says that there adventure during that
week counted is one of Morty's 10 free adventures
rips up his adventure card which itself was
a callback to season three with the adventure
card itself and Morty complains about having
wanted to go to boo world Rick saying that
he can't now, but then turns to offer summer
a trip to Boob World she says maybe later
cut to later, we're in season five now in
their actually doing it your seeing the lyrics
of the song.
The lyrics themselves are a joke about the
world basically being two worlds.
Because the pair of boobs they got special
hats on, they actually had Darren criss back.
I believe he was the yellow gotron pilot at
the end of the episode.
But he also saying the boo world theme song
over the end credits to this Darren criss
singing but then Rick reveals the only reason
why summer actually got invited is because
boob world had all these problems with anti-sexism
protest for the past 30 years in they just
rebranded as a boob quote unquote empowerment
experience if they bring a woman they get
in for free in the reference to the coke can
in Six Flags is actually a thing in real life
I actually grew up in the Midwest near Six
Flags nowadays you can still get a discount
on your passes by bringing empty Coke cans
with the discount used to be way bigger back
in the day summer invents a new were just
combining a couple different words for excited
stoked inside which they pay off in the next
scene after she replaces Morty is Rick's number
two with Morty trying to invent a word to
seem cool to then Rick spots the last remaining
gotron fair that he's been trying to collect
for a long time in excess of the actual plot
of the episode gotron fair is being their
version of the Voltron liens he yanks out
the previous dead pilot skeleton stillness
uniform throws it out sort of setting up the
twist later in the episode where they go around
either killing or just stealing the other robots
The whole subplot with the dueling internal
monologues is basically a big play on Raley
Liotta's internal monologue from the Goodfellas
movie.
Because a lot of the later jokes do parody
the Goodfellas movie and summer's internal
monologue basically start stepping all over
Morty's internal monologue and later at the
end of the episode.
They also call that out to saying that they
were parasites the whole time.
Internal monologue parasites which remind
you of the season two Total Recall episode
with the parasites that were showing up in
fake memories picking up all kinds of random
parasites in their adventures all over the
universe.
They have that funny spoilers joke when Morty
tries to explain how they're all going to
combine Rick and Summer just yelling spoilers
out of which you could also say wound up being
a very timely reference is this whole episode
basically leaked out a couple weeks early
and there were spoilers everywhere.
So a lot of you actually probably watch this
episode a couple weeks ago to make another
reference to Jean their neighbor who Rick
ran over during the episode where Morty and
summer's baby came from.
With the giant sperm monsters were attacking
everyone on their street.
There were a number of different references
to that earlier episodes.
Setting up the big twist later when the baby
comes back.
There were several parts during the episode
were different characters in different scenes
basically recap the entire plot of that earlier
episode.
Remember the time of the giant.
They be the got fired in outer space by the
government if you that was weird how many
times they reference the plot of that episode.
It was all just to remind people.
I think is a been a couple weeks.
Like a remember the time we did this because
it's going to be a really big thing a couple
minutes Beth literally calls the baby out
right after this.
Saying that that was the end of them getting
really excited about doing things as a family
then summer calls it out sarcastically in
references several other major plot twists
in the show's history.
Like Beth wondering if she's a clone or not
from season three.
We actually just saw space Beth come back
at the beginning of season five summer saying
that she only exists because they failed to
abort her is a callback to season one's interdimensional
cable episode summer then also makes an anime
reference.
That's a deep cut reference for the original
anime series.
The Voltron was based on Voltron is just the
westernized cartoon version of the anime series
beast King go lion.
They play another internal monologue joke
on Morty and then they do their big Voltron
montage of them.
Zip lining to all the gotron ferrets in each
place that they go to just it's like a little
less cool until you get to Morty's which is
parked in an actual parking garage Jerry calling
out how ridiculous some of it is like what
I zip line all the way to Hawaii just a rendezvous
above my house in orbit is them just joking
about the logic of the actual Voltron series.
Rick integrates his portal gun technology
with the gotron ferrets to open a portal to
the nipple Doug system where they fight the
first big alien kaiju in they basically play
it as if Rick is trying to enact his adult
fantasy like he's an adult toy collector collecting
giant toys he has his very specific way that
he wants this to play out.
So he's waiting to reveal all these things
in the family, but in doing this.
He's also calling out a lot of the tropes
of a lot of these big Mac anime series fighting
kaiju like first you have to all fight it
separately in a really bad way.
So we get our asses kicked then we rally form
the giant robot he gets.
But little more then also setting up another
big twist when he forms the energy sword from
Voltron to the making fun of Anime tropes
will also making fun of a lot of adult toy
collectors in Rick just going crazy trying
to collect all these ferrets a lot of times
when they have jokes on the series about Rick
being obsessed with collecting toys.
Like the Nintendo rant from a couple seasons
ago.
That's then actually making fun of Justin
Roiland most the time because he's such a
huge toy collector in real life it for example
the Nintendo rant was something that Justin
Roiland did in real life.
He just came into the rick and Morty writer's
room one day, yelling about a scheme to make
money on Nintendo DS collector additions and
they turn it into a bit during an episode.
If you ever watch the behind the scenes with
Justin with him in interviews in his old house,
he also has toys just stacked up all over
his house Morty has another Raley Otis Goodfellow
style internal monologue teaming up the beginning
of the end.
Like everything was awesome until rick started
to go off the rails.
As if his internal monologue is speaking in
past tense this whole time during the episode.
They said the whole multiverse Voltron twist
Rick calls a bunch of alternate reality Rick's
and it goes full Goodfellas a lot of these
mobster parities are parodies from many different
mob movies Jerry reveals that he ready to
blow someone to avoid being kicked off the
team setting up the joke during the episode
Jerry being gay which they pay off later with
yo-yo Rick the band playing at their cookout
is the same banned from season two episode
10 at birdperson's wedding Morty gets bummed
out when he finds out the he's the only Morty here
Who hasn't been to boob world, all the different
Rick's here.
Like is that are parodies of different famous
mob movies like, there's the Godfather version
of rick that they're calling big fat Rick
Ricardo Montoya is a version of Scarface later
in the episode, they actually go full Scarface
with the end of the episode in the end that
movie hothead Rick is just a version of sunny
from the first Godfather movie and little
Ricky wrap it up as a version of Joe Pesci's
character from Goodfellas to make a joke about
how they try to create all these different
characters like they're all supposed to be
very different versions of rick yet, they
somehow have the exact same size face is more
of an animator joke than anything else hothead
Rick makes another reference the giant space baby
Like I said they reference the plot of that
episode several times he basically recap the
entire plot of that episode, then when C1
37 rick says are we ever going to live that
down that sort of a meta reference the writers
basically saying are we ever going to live
down that really joke from that episode.
Like maybe giant space baby with Morty and
summer was a little too far.
The whole thing with the gotron fair blowing
up in hotheaded Rick's face.
I think is just a reference to sunny getting
killed off during the Godfather something
similar happens later in the episode to where
he gets lit on fire.
Like he has this gruesome death in in the
Godfather movie sunny dies a very gruesome
death replace him with yo-yo Rick the also
try to justify him with that meta reference
about how he's cool despite being lame because
he owns his lameness there are several points
in the episode where it did feel like the
writers were making fun of themselves for
some lame jokes they have that big Goodfellas
montage of them taking out a ton of competition
to go get everyone's gotron ferrets in different
universes killing people off stealing them.
You could call this a reference to almost
any mob movie montage almost all of the big
famous mob movies have montages like this
before things go off the rails then summer's
internal monologue explains how Rick's scheme
works.
They keep adding more and more gotron ferrets
so each combined group of five also forms
another giant gotron they call the first one
the go gotron later they make an even bigger
one to the end of the episode.
They go around everyone's different universe
basically being on kilovolt paying off Rick's
earlier reference saying that they're literally
too big to fail because the go gotron the
even bigger version of the robot is literally
bigger than all the other kaiju they're fighting
except for the giant space baby at the end
of the episode.
The other parody song this week is all about
combining pasta with anime they have the boob
world theme song at the end of the episode.
The Darren criss think this one during their
montage is about pasta and anime because the
mob movie parodies in the Voltron during this
montage you notice some of the kaiju kills
are also parodies of trophy mob movie kills
like 100 giant buckets of cement for the centipede
kaiju that they then drowned in the ocean.
Then things start to go off the rails the
different Rick start to argue with each other
in they get rid of yo-yo Rick by blackmailing
him using a version of Jerry is another version
of Jerry but is them paying off the Jerry
might be gay reference from earlier in the
episode saying the was ready to blow someone
summer takes his place.
He knows that now she's wearing a black lion
suit basically means that she took yo-yo Rick
spot on the team Summer makes a Borat movie
reference when she's dissing Morty and Rick
start to go crazy summer explaining that he's
distorting detergent and it becomes the big
Scarface parody with 20 when Tana getting
high on his own supply like he taps his nose
and yells at summer to get a more the whole
bit with the nightclub and Morty being an
associate security chief feels like a casino
movie parody with Robert De Niro another solid
mob movie the dress that summer's wearing
also seems a little like the dress that Sharon
Stone wore during the movie casino Rick calls
her oakleaf summer just squeaked and Morty's
face a little while ago.
Rick then explains the even larger go go gotron
which is 100 ferrets combined and Morty gets
captured by the enemy characters that they
stole the ferrets from earlier.
Like I said I think the yellow one here is
voiced by Darren criss, because part of the
title of the episode is taken from Evangelion
in this character is a redheaded anime character
who pilots a giant space robot I'm assuming
that this is meant to be a parody of Asuka
Langley from eva probably the most famous
redheaded pilot in all of neck anime you notice
that all the anime characters are also animated
as if they are anime characters inside a Rick
and Morty in episode with the stereo typical
physical traits in expressions of anime characters.
That's why they say that they're literally
designed for piloting the robots because they
are anime characters and they call what Rick
is doing appropriation is in cultural appropriation
they try to bribe Morty with boob world money
and when Morty drags himself back is a whole
bunch of references here in the graffiti the
wall reads get Capone which is a reference
to getting Pwnd and Al Capone because of all
the mob jokes some of the graffiti reads gun
dumb a play on the gun them franchise of the
big neck anime series is a bunch of other
names here to some of these names might be
animators who worked on the episode hotheaded
Rick betrays the group.
Like I said he dies a gruesome death like
sunny died a gruesome death during the Godfather
movie Jerry makes another joke about being
gay telling a story about traveling alone
on a flight to Paris trying to get over a
breakup you could also say that them kicking
Morty off the team is a reference to Michael
Corleone pushing freight oocyte before he
had them killed.
Rick betrays summer by replacing her with
the redheaded asuka Langley parody anime girl
who tried to bribe Morty.
She's also reading a gun dumb magazine which
has an actual gundam on the cover she says
that she is a bunch of temps lined up with
previous robot experience obviously.
That's a reference the big betrayal at the
end of the episode there that brief bit about
beth and Jerry being tainted by their time
working in the Rick Voltron Mafia wanted to
have summer back then wanted to kill themselves
and wait for her at the doors to hell.
So they can kill her again Morty calls it
out and they turn on a dime the minute she
walks and crying out being fired by Rick and
she explains her secret history with the space baby
Which itself turns into a huge parody of the
movie arrival with Amy Adams which is a great movie
If you haven't seen it they make an abortion
joke while she's taking that up in the funny
thing we learn about this because this is
all Canon now is that the US government the
president has a secret military base on Mars.
So the president probably knew about baby
narrow toe this whole time we find of the
government wanted to use him as a giant weapon.
But summer cared about him help them escape
then setting up the big reveal at the end
of the episode with a pilot it like a giant
kaiju alien when they go back to rick and
the giant go go gotron it's literally Tony
Montana's office from the end of the Scarface movie
and they basically do the end of the movie within
being betrayed and all the other anime characters
coming for them.
He does a parody of that famous line say hello
to my little me pulling a little Rick shape
gun and Morty and the rest of the family swoop
in on giant baby narrow toe saving the day
got a giant American flag diaper his wristband
reads weapon one the minute 80085 reference
is just boobs spelled backwards.
Which is also a callback to rick secret code
word from earlier this season with that he
used to control of the duplicate families.
It also reads made in Las Vegas because that's
where Morty sperm fertilize summer's egg.
So the baby was literally made in Las Vegas
the baby is super OP just completely swats
the giant robot away.
They get rid of the anime characters then
they explained the end of the episode that
even though everything is fine with the family
again now because they get rid of all the
ferrets now alien kaiju are coming to earth
unchallenged in millions of people are already
dead like it's no big deal that they don't
care about it all also trapping Jerry outside
racing the blast shields on the house up they've
actually done that raised the blast shields
on the house almost in every single episode
during season five.
When Morty and summer have the final dueling
internal monologue scene wrapping of the episode.
The path the parasites joke with Rick shooting
both of them calling them voiceover variance,
then rolling his eyes and gagging as if it's
him making fun of this joke.
This whole bit with the voiceover for being
lame I wouldn't call it a 4th wall break.
But it is the writers basically calling themselves
out for doing a lame joke, then during the
post credit scene.
They do a big twist on the whole kaiju trope
from anime series about how in anime series
kaiju often come from other dimensions or
of the world.
But in the rick and Morty multiverse their
secretly highly intelligent creatures trying
to help humanity by giving them the cure for
AIDS but in traveling through their interdimensional
portal the stripped of all their intelligence
and close making them seem like terrible monsters.
If you're paying attention the subtitles apparently
the cure for AIDS in the rick and Morty multiverse
is just basically preserved lemons the recipe
the kaiju tells them one part lemon juice
four-part bay leaves one pinch of sea salt
is basically the recipe you used for preserving lemons
But if you spotted any other big Easter eggs
in the episode that I didn't talk about during
the video just right them blown the comments
my full Rick and Morty season five episode
eight video will post next week.
Just like normal marvel's what if episodes
are also going to start next week to I'll
be doing videos for all those episodes.
Just like Rick and Morty just like the marvel
Loki episodes it will heavily trade on the
multiverse inside the MCU make sure you have
alerts enabled so you don't miss any those episodes
I also just did a big venom two trailer video
you can click here to watch that and you can
click here for that brand-new marvel what
if trailer in new shang chi trailer video easter eggs
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next video!